anne céline vous est certainement l'une
des des romanciers les plus lus dans le
monde je rappellerai quelques uns
boutique enfin le plus célèbre en tout
cas qui s'appelle multiples splendeurs
beaucoup de gens lui des millions de
personnes mais aussi la montagne et
jeunes l'arbre aux blessés une fleur
mortels et beaucoup d'autres mais ce que
ces romans sont lus en chine oui on élit
actuellement ils sont tous ses duels
varices ans après la révolution
culturelle ils sont tous entrés dans la
tête on élit en anglais il y à des
extraits maintenant chinois oui et je
fais aussi des conférences en chine je
parle évidemment à tous mes amis
écrivains j'en connais plusieurs
centaines j'ai parlé aussi par exemple
à littérature chinoise récemment sont
très curieux de savoir ce qui se passe
dans la littérature européenne et
j'envoie tout le temps des livres de
france d'angleterre d'amérique
je vous envoie mes amis en chine mais
les téléspectateurs français sont très
curieux de savoir qui vous êtes je vous
rappelle que vous êtes né d'un père
chinois d'une mère belge
vous êtes chinoise et que au fond d'une
mine au chili ce que je vis un peu dans
mes valises mais je m'arrange a passé à
peu près l'année en quatre quelques mois
en chine quelques mois en inde avec mon
mari qui est indien quelques mois en
europe au gène résidence à lausanne est
alors quelques mois en amérique parce
que ma fille est mariée à new york
j'ai donc plusieurs familles j'ai une
famille chinoise une famille indienne
une famille américaine est évidemment
encore une famille belge à bruxelles
vous savez ce que vous exercez encore
non j'ai dire si durant 15 ans j'étais
pédiatre j'ai fait j'ai pratiqué la
médecine durant 15 en asie ce qui a été
très important
et puis en 1965 à cause de la guerre du
vietnam
je me suis dit que je ne pouvais plus
rester muette et je suis parti pour
l'amérique où j'ai fait des conférences
contre la guerre du vietnam
à ce moment-là 65 avec les attraits
idiots les américains me disais mais
dans trois mois on aura fini tout ça les
ordinateurs nous ont dit qu'on a qu'à
taper sur un asiatique il se rend je
leur ai dit dans trois ans dans trente
ans vous y serez encore trois ans après
évidemment j'avais raison et alors
depuis lors je fais des conférences
passe comme elle le demande mais si on
me demandait de faire autre chose je
préférais quand même retourné à la
médecine écrire le soir je faisais
savent et vous considérez comme en
commune par rapport aux autres chinoise
comme une bourgeoise ne tenait pas je
suis bourgeoise bien sûr puisque je
vienne
non je ne suis pas descendu de
prolétaires je suis descendu d'une
famille bourgeoise et comme vous le
lirez d'hormones et moi j'aime aussi
justement et je m'excuse en amérique ça
arrive très souvent que les américains
je sais je sais mais ici vous êtes très
gentils vous prenez la peine de le lire
c'est vraiment je suis très touché je
trouve que n'est ce pas je l'expliqué
que la bourgeoisie en chine nous fait
partie du peuple
c'est donc n'est ce pas là une chose que
peu d'européens comprennent pas ce que
je crois qu'ici
peut-être vous avez plus de dogmatisme
là dessus mais si vous lisez mon livre
vous verrez que dès le commencement mois
du tour a dit que la bourgeoisie ferait
partie du peuple c'est à dire qu'elle a
les droits de vote et tous et que si
elle ne sabotent pas le socialisme est
là elle s'intègre dans le peuple les
enfants vont à l'école il n'y a rien
contre la bourgeoisie ou la petite
bourgeoisie oui j'aurais posé deux
questions par parenthèse d'abord vu
qu'ils sont d'abord and swing quel est
votre prénom dans quelques villes prénom
unique comme tous les chinois nous
mettons toujours le nom de famille
d'abord et nous même après parce que
nous trouvons simple et logique que de
se mettre d'abord est le nom de famille
après andy marte c'est tout c'est la
famille m'a c'est un show alors là aussi
dans votre vie vos bernard a très bien
parfois on fait ça lacombe lucien voilà
là mais le show est comme ça qu il faut
préciser le une chose qui m'a surpris
c'est que par mao tsé toung twillight
ordinairement français on les écrit en
trois petits morceaux chou et la
dans votre livre ses deux cheminées à
mende ça c'est une invention
oui parce que je trouve que mettre le
petit rets massa ne veut rien dire et
vous voyez comme je suis français je
m'excuse
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un usage les
usages sont faits pour être cassée
remplacés par d'autres qui se sert le
président sait prédire que le président
allemand
au moins c'est vous voyez pour anne
fouillées une par exemple je devrais
avoir un très bas parce que tous les
mots chinois sont monosyllabiques donc
je vais voir sous traitement in j'ai
trouvé que cette année et je trouve que
c'est beaucoup plus joli sur les crimes
à se tourner
n'est ce pas là et c est probablement
qu'un jour les gens le feront
automatiquement une autre petite
précision avant-hier au magazine c'est à
dire lionel stoléru keita des
conseillers du président république a
quitté l'émission parce que des
sinologues parlait comme ça très
familièrement du président du domaine
out c'est tout le sens dira le président
mao tsé toung
est ce que c'est vraiment lui faire
injure que le dire maintenant moi je dis
que j'aime en acceptant je ne crois pas
que c'était une injure mais on m'a dit
je ne sais pas on m'a dit que ce n'était
pas à cause de cela que 7 à cause de
certaines autres altercations mais je ne
sais pas est pas là mais si si je dit
mao comme ça de brutalement ça va pas
couper les relations internationales
entre la france et la chine se faisait
bon aucunement et vous assure adan et
dans les campagnes chinoises
on l'appelle le vieux bonhomme ce vieux
bonhomme avec affection parce que vous
savez qu'il est très populaire il est
très aimé et
les gens l'appellent loggia ce qui veut
dire le vieux bonhomme est et on ne va
pas la tête pour ça en chine vous venez
donc de publier aux éditions stock le
premier jour du monde qui est la suite
du déluge du matin du matin racontait la
chine avant la révolution de 49 et dans
ce deuxième volume vous raconter le
président mao la chine la révolution
chinoise de 1949 à nos jours c'est bien
ça jusqu en août 1975 75 alors il ya une
première question parce qu'on va revenir
sur votre vie dans un instant pourquoi
avez-vous dédié spécialement cet ouvrage
au peuple français
parce que en faisant ce durant ses 20
ans et cela m'a pris 20 ans d étude très
approfondie sur tout ce qui s'est passé
en chine
et vous savez je n'ai pas commencé par
croire parce que je ne suis pas
dogmatique je ne suis pas une liste je
ne crois même pas au marxisme ont-elles
que théorie il fallait que je voie en
faisant tout cela je me suis rendu
compte que la révolution française la
commune de paris ce que la france avait
fait dans le monde avait une influence
en chine qui d'ailleurs est dans mon
livre et comment durant la révolution
culturelle
la commune de paris par exemple a été
cité maintes fois comment par exemple
l'international en chine qui est
d'ailleurs la chanson n'est ce pas de la
république populaire commémore toujours
le jour de gênes potier le français
qu'il a écrit et eugène pottier la
biographie de jeunes poitiers ce que la
vie d'eugène pottier a été traduites en
chinois
alors dans tout cela je trouve une
influence je trouve aussi une influence
dans par exemple le vice premier
ministre
thank you pin qui comme vous le savez a
passé une partie de sa jeunesse en
france monsieur john est le premier
ministre et je crois que oui que il ya
eu et il y encore en chine
une impression que la france que le
peuple français a contribué beaucoup à
l'histoire du monde à l'éveil des
peuples et que ça pourrait continuer